YOU, TREY.
TREY: JOINING ME NOW, HOUSE
G.O.P. CHAIRWOMAN NEW YORK
CONGRESSWOMAN ALISE
STEFANIK.
WELCOME TO YOU, WHY DO YOU
THINK THAT GLENN YOUNGKIN
SUCCEEDED WHERE OTHER
REPUBLICANS HAVE NOT?
>> WELL, GLENN YOUNGKIN WAS
AN
EXCEPTIONAL, ANAKIN --
CANDIDATE.
HE MADE EDUCATION A
PRIORITY.
THAT ALLOWED HIM TO GROW HIS
BASE.
FROM EVERYONE WHO ARE FED UP
WITH STATUS QUO.
AND HE RAN ON THE ECONOMY.
MAKING SURE THAT VIRGINIA IS
FROM HIS PERSPECTIVE, THE
STRONG ESTATE IN THE NATION
TO CREATE JOBS AND GROW
SMALL BUSINESSES AS THEY
HAVE STRUGGLED WITH RECOVERY
AFTER COVID, HE RAN AS A BIG
TENT REPUBLICAN, HE DID WELL
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES, WE WON
BY 27 POINTS BUT ALSO IN
SUBURBS.
HE EXPANDED OUR SUPPORT
AMONG HISPANICS,
AFRICAN-AMERICAN, SUBURBAN
WOMEN, THIS IS ABOUT
ADDITION NOT SUBTRACTTION
THIS IS CANDIDATES MATTER
AND YOUR MESSAGE MATTERS.
ON FLIP SIDE,
DEMOCRATS RAN A CAMPAIGN OF
THE PAST, TERRY MCCAULIFFE
TALKED MORE ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP THAN GLENN YOUNGKIN,
WE REMEMBER IN END TERRY
MCCAULIFFE BROUGHT IN SIR
--
SURROGATES FROM PAST THAT
INCLUDE FORMER PRESIDENT
BARACK OBAMA AND A HEAD OF
FORMER STATE TEACHER UNION,
IT WAS A DEMOCRATIC CAMPAIGN
OF THE PAST NOT FUTURE, AND
RESULTS SHOWED AT BALLOT BOX
WITH A OVERWHELMING WIN NOT
JUST GLENN YOUNGKIN BUT MOST
DIVERSE TICKET WITH WINSOME
SEARS AS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
SCAN DATE. CANDIDATE.
TREY: REPUBLICANS DID NOT
ALWAYS DO WELL WITH WOMEN
VOTERS ARE YOUNG MOMS, LUCKY
FOR ME YOU ARE BOTH,
CONGRATULATIONS, HOW CAN
REPUBLICANS NOTE IN VIRGINIA
TAKENESE LESSONS AND APPLY
THEM.
>> I THINK BRINGING SOLUTION
IS IMPORTANT, ISSUE OF
EDUCATION.
I CAN TELL YOU, I THINK A
LOT ABOUT MAKING SURE HE HAS
THE BEST EDUCATION POSSIBLE.
REPUBLICANS ARE THE PARTY OF
PARENTS, DEMOCRATS ARE PARTY
OF THE FAILING STATUS QUO,
THEY PRIOR TEASE TEACHERS
UNION INSTEAD OF STUDENTS
AND PARENTS AND TEACHERS,
THIS RACE SHOWED THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS TRULY
THE PARTY OF PARENTS, I
SERVE ON EDUCATION
COMMITTEE, THIS SAY GROWTH
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO SHARE
OUR MESSAGE.
ING IN ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
IS HUGE FOR WORKING MOMS,
MAKING SURE THERE ARE GOOD
PAYING JOBS, AND INFLATION
IS HAVING AN IMPACT UP AND
DOWN THE BALLOT IN SOME
WAYS, JUDGMENT ON JOE
BIDEN'S FAILED ECONOMIC
POLICIES AS WORKING MOMS,
WOMEN SEE THE INFLATED COST
WHETHER THE GROCERY STORE OR
DIAPERS, I SEE THOSE COSTS
GO UP MONTH-TO-MONTH.
TREY: YOU KNOW,
CONGRESSWOMAN, SOMETIMES
WINNERS MISREAD A NARROW
VICTORY INTO A MANDATE AND
EVERY NOW AND AGAIN, PEOPLE
THAT LOSE MAKE A LOT OF
EXCUSES OTHER THAN THE
OBVIOUS.
YOU VOTED THIS WEEK.
AFTER THE VIRGINIA ELECTION
RESULTS.
DID YOUR COLLEAGUES ON OTHER
SIDE OF AISLE LEARN ANYTHING
OR ARE THEY REALLY GOING
BIGGER AND FASTER?
>> THEY ARE DOUBLING DOWN.
HOUSE DEMOCRAT ATTEMPTS TO
GO BIGGER AND FASTER AND
MORE SPENDING.
WE ALREADY FACING AN
ECONOMIC CRISIS WHETHER
LABOR SHORTAGE COUPLED
WIN -- WITH THE INFLATION
CRISIS, DEMOCRAT DISCUSSING
BIGGEST SPENDING PACKAGE AND
LARGEST TAX HIKE IN 4
NATION'S HISTORY, THEY DID
NOT LEARN THE LESSONS OF
VIRGINIA, NOT FAR LEFT
SOCIALIST IDEAS THAT VOTERS
ARE LOOKING FOR, THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR CANDIDATES THAT
STAND UP FOR ISSUES THAT
MATTER TO THEM WITH
SOLUTIONS, BUT NANCY PELOSI
AND BEING CONTROLLED BY THE
FAR LEFT.
SO IN COMING WEEKS WE'LL SEE
AS THEY NEGOTIATE THEIR
TRILLION DOLLAR TACK AND
SPEND -- TAX AND SPEND
PACKAGE HOW COSTLY IT WILL
BE FOR AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHAT IS IMPORTANT, THEY
WANTED TO VOTE ON THIS
BEFORE A
CONGRESS OFFERS SCORE THAT
MEANS GETTING RID OF
WASHINGTON SPEAK, THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW COSTLY IT WOULD BE
TO TAXPAYERS AND HOW
SIGNIFICANT TAX INCREASES
WOULD BE, AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE TO KNOW THE COST,
TRUE COST OF HOW MANY
TRILLIONS THIS WILL TAKEOVER
THE NEXT DECADE.
TREY: CONGRESSWOMAN, I HOPE
YOU ARE ACTIVELY INVOLVED
WITH LEADER McCARTHY AND
OTHERS IN SETTING AGENDA AND
PICKING CANDIDATES FOR FALLS
THAT HAS ALL MAKES OF A
SUCCESSFUL FALL IF
REPUBLICANS CAN AVOID
BLOWING IT YOU SAY SAM IS 10
WEEKS OLD.
>> YES.
TREY: I'M SURE HE IS
ALREADY READING KNOWING YOU,
AS SMART AS YOU ARE, I LOOK
FORWARD TO VISITING WITH YOU
AGAIN.
>> WE LE